what's imagination
does it require the past does it require
the future does it require memory does
it so imagination
does it only exist in the moment so
imagination is
yeah probably it's an instantaneous
readout of what's going on you can maybe
your
your subconscious brain has been
generating all the all the bits for it
but no imagination occurs
when you
in your game engine you you remember the
past and you integrate sensory the
present and you try and work out what
you want to do in the future and then
you go and make that happen
so the imagination is this it's like
imagine asking what imagination is about
asking what surfing is
you can see you can surfboard surfer
wave coming in when you're on that wave
and you're surfing
that's where the imagination is i think
i think imagination is just accessing
things that aren't the present moment in
the present moment so like i can i'm
sitting here and i'm looking at the
table and i can imagine
the river in things or whatever it was
and so it seems to be that it's like
it's our ability to access
things that aren't present but so
conjure up worlds some of them might be
akin to
something that happened to you recently
right but they don't have they don't
have to be things that actually happen
in your past and i think this gets back
to assembly theory like the way i would
think about imagination from an assembly
theoretic standpoint is i'm a giant
causal graph
um and i exist in a present moment as a
particular configuration of sarah
and
but there's a lot of i carry a lot of
evolutionary baggage i have that whole
causal history and i can
access parts of it now when you talk
about getting to something as complex as
us having as large assembly space as us
there's ways of
like there's a lot of things in that
causal graph that have ever actually
never existed in the past history of the
universe because like the universe got
big enough to contain
the three of us in this room
in time
but
not all the features of each one of us
individually
have come into existence as physical
objects we would recognize as individual
objects this goes back to your point
that we actually have to explain why why
things
actually even look like objects and
aren't just a smear of
mess
and just on the the free will and
physics thing
when you were talking i was i just want
to bring this up because i think it's a
really interesting viewpoint that
nicholas jizzin has that um you know
like we want to use the laws of physics
and then say you can't have free will
and his point is you have to have free
will in order to even choose to set up
an experiment to test the laws of
physics so in some sense free will
should be more fundamental than physics
is to because to even do science there's
some assumption
that
the agents have free will and i always
thought it was really perplexing that
um
you know physics wants to remove agency
because the idea that i could do an
experiment here on this part of earth
and then i can move somewhere else and
prepare an identically you know
identically prepared experiment run an
experiment again seems to imply
something about the structure of our
universe that is not encoded in the laws
that we're testing in those experiments
so this kind of dream of physics that
you can do multiple experiments
different locations and then validate
each other
you're saying that's uh that's an
illusion
no i'm saying that requires decision
making and free will to be a real thing
i think
like i think that i think the fact that
we can do science is not arbitrary
and i think people you know the standard
canon in physics would be well you could
trace all of that back to the initial
condition in the universe but though the
whole point of science is i can imagine
doing the experiment and i can do it and
then i can do it again and again and
again all over the place to you
imagination somehow fundamentally
generative of novelty yes so it's not
like the universe could have predicted
the things you imagined imagination
super so coming back to novelty i think
novelty can exist outside of imagination
but it supercharges it it's another
transition i think
i mean i would say
i mean this may be a boring statement
but i would say that they're sorry i'm
not sure it's a heart these are hard
questions yeah i mean i think the fact
that objects exist is yet another proof
that
that time is fundamental and novelty
exists right
because i think again if you ask a
physicist to write down in their
infinite bible of the universe let's
call it the bible the the ma you know
matebook
the mathematical universe whether you're
max tag mark or sean carroll or frank
wilcheck
[Laughter]
or or stephen wolfram okay yeah
i like that bucket yeah i love it too
lots of pretty pictures
it's really interesting that they they
cope with the enormity of the universe
by saying well it's all their
mathematics it all exists right and and
i would say that
that's why i'm excited about the future
of the universe because it
it although it is somehow dependent upon
the past
it is not constrained
just by the past
which is kind of mad
yeah that's what free will is it's not
constrained by the past it's dependent
on the past
this moment it's not just dependent this
moment is the past and yet it has the
capacity to generate a totally
unpredictable future i mean the other
thing i would say is super important for
human beings right human beings have
actually very little causal control in
the future
i realized this the other week yeah yeah
so what happened to what so this is what
i think it is the way
by reinterpreting your past i mean talk
about from a kind of cognitive
psychological cognitive point of view by
reinterpreting your past
in your current mind
you can actually helps you shape your
future again
so you but you you have much more
freedom to interpret your past to act in
the present to change your future than
you do to change your future it may
sound weird so i'm saying everybody
imagine your past think about your past
reinterpret your past in the nicest way
you can
then imagine what you can do next or
imagine your past in a more negative way
and what you do next and look at those
two counterfactuals they're different
yeah it's fast i mean daniel kahneman
talks about this the most of our life is
lived in our memories it's interesting
because you can essentially in
imagination choose the life you live so
maybe free will exist in imagination
choices are made in your imagination
and that results in you basically able
to control how the future unrolls
because you're like
imagining
like reinterpreting constantly the
things that happen to you exactly so
you're the if you want to increase your
amount of free will those people that
have most i don't think everyone has
equal amounts of agency because of uh
because of our sad sad constraints
whether whether you know happenstance
with health
economic
born born in a certain place right
but
your those of us that have the ability
to go back and reinterpret our past
and and and use that to change the
future
are the ones that exert most agency in
the present
and i i want to i want to achieve
higher degrees of agency and enable
everyone else to do that as well to have
more fun
in the universe
you